there's always two versions of this show
there's the show that we plan to do and
the show that we trip
into right now what we're going to do
miles we're going to go through the 32
teams rapid fire and we're going to do a
yes no
do we think they would be interested i
may handle some of them because it's
obvious and i'll start with the afc east
bills
are absolutely not jets
jets i can't imagine would they
would they move sam darnold and say come
to town for a year ben rothsberger i
can't imagine the jets would do that
i can't either that wouldn't seem to
make sense i mean robert solids is first
year they're not expected to be super
bowl contender they're not a qb away
from anything
i wouldn't say the jets and he's gonna
have to want to go to a team where he
thinks
he can make a difference and pursue a
championship
and do to the steelers what tom brady
did to the patriots all right
patriots speaking of speaking of the
patriots
need a quarterback i i the patriot way
and ben roethlisberger do not seem to
mesh in my mind
no but i think we might have said the
same thing about cam newton right
and it didn't man it didn't work no it's
not cam's fault they didn't have any
help around him
that's the reason for ben to not want it
ben's coming from this group
of every guy they draft turns to gold
every receiver pick him round two round
seven round wherever and he's great
and then you come up to the place where
if you gave him 100 draft picks they
wouldn't find a good receiver so
i i think i think he would be
disinclined to join the patriots from
that perspective
dolphins could he be the new fitz to tua
i don't think he'd want that
i don't think i if i'm too uh there's no
way i would want that ether
um but i i think the dolphins are
another place where it's kind of like
yeah you know if your qb plays a little
bit
better then that elevates you but i
don't know that
miami should be looking for that
short-term solution rather than a
long-term solution
i wouldn't throw tua overboard for ben
there are other guys where i would say
like if i can get to sean watson sorry
tool we love you but we're taking
deshaun watson russell wilson
sorry tua but with ben i think you stick
with tua
all right uh the ravens absolutely not
the browns absolutely not although that
that would be fascinating to see him
play
for the team closest to where he grew up
the bengals have joe burrow
uh raiders okay this is a great test
because the raiders are always looking
mike mayok the gm of the team
constantly says we're always searching
for an upgrade at every position
i wouldn't want ben rothersberger over
derek carr right now would you
no i don't think that i would uh because
derek carr can get things done i
i don't think derek carr was the main
issue for the raiders last season i
think
that that offense has to get better in
the red zone and i don't necessarily
know
that ben roethlisberger is going to be
able to make you do that
um also i mean as we show the graphic
now like look they're deep passing
there's another thing that the raiders
had problems with
whether it was i load the scheme or
derek carter didn't necessarily want to
fire it down the field he did a little
bit more last year than he has in the
past but
i don't know that ben roethlisberger
would be the solution
for the raiders if you really want to
upgrade i don't see roethlisberger as an
upgraded derek carr at this point
the best part about it though would be
given the overall size of ben
roethlisberger
that he and gruden could do like a
ventriloquist dummy routine where gruden
could sit on his lap and pretend to be
the
the wooden dummy and ben could be the
ventriloquist that would be worth it
right there
uh chargers and chiefs absolutely not
they have their franchise guys
uh sliding over to the nfc um
uh oh we did we didn't mention denver oh
denver we got to go denver oh and i
forgot the
well who i forgot the fc south sorry i
hope it's it's easy to forget the afc
south
we've got the denver broncos they've got
drew locke
um and and they don't seem to be sold on
drew locke
again to you know they they went for
peyton manning and it worked for five
years
ben roethlisberger is a one to two year
fix
they weren't interested in philip rivers
last year they still thought they had
something in drew lock could you see the
broncos making that move
this one i actually could see because i
don't know that the broncos are
championship caliber but i think going
into next year
vic fangio was one of these guys that
might be on the hot seat or at least
should be thinking about hey
how can i keep my job he's gotta win
probably seven eight nine games these
need to be over 500 especially because
they also have a new general manager so
this is one where i could maybe see it
especially because look they've got guys
like noah fent they've got cortland
sutton they've got jerry judy
there are pieces there that maybe could
make for a successful
offense mike yeah but do you want to
step into a division with the chiefs and
the chargers who i think are going to be
a lot better this year as justin herbert
develops
the path to the super bowl is a little
bit rockier in that division
all right i did skip over the south
sorry teams of the south we talked about
the colts already though that's the only
team in that division
that jumps out to me the titans have
ryan tannehill under contract the
jaguars are most likely going to get
trevor lawrence i can't imagine them
saying let's put the
the possibility of getting a 10 to 15
year starter on hold for a
a one year run with ben rothersberger
and then the texans
now that would be an interesting sitcom
jackie used to be in ben roethlisberger
that that would be
fun but i don't think either side would
be interested there
i'd love to see it though i really would
they get rid of deshawn watson and bring
in ben roethlisberger that's fun
yeah uh it would be fun if you're a
texans fan
there's another word that starts with
fnu that you would be saying
all right uh nfc east look the cowboys
we assume they're gonna keep dak
prescott
the eagles i don't i don't correct me
farmer i mean
they've got jalen hurts they're talking
about drafting a guy with the sixth
overall pick i don't think they're gonna
ride with ben how about washington
though they're looking
they're they you you were you you
covered the panthers you know ron rivera
you think ron rivera would be interested
in a year with ben
i i think that like i said washington i
think would make sense
at least for a little bit that one year
maybe they bring him in and then they
also
try to draft and develop another guy i
think that especially as we're saying
earlier in that nfc
east they're they're they want it going
seven and nine
already so i think if we see them have a
qb
who can maybe do a couple things throw
the ball down the field if they get a
good running game
that defense i think led by chase young
is
good enough that they might be a
quarterback away
from really being a above 500 contending
team as opposed to a below 500
contending team
i think washington might make sense and
if the path to the super bowl the
difficulty is what
would be one of the factors for ben
first of all you get an easy path to win
the division
relatively speaking especially in
comparison to some of the divisions we
were talking about in the afc
and uh look the general consensus is all
the best teams are in the afc the super
bowl winners in the nfc
but the you know they have a a more
top-heavy collection of great teams in
the afc
the uh the giants have daniel jones i
can't imagine them doing anything let's
move the nfc north
packers and and lions have their guys
for 2021 the vikings have their guy
they're locked into kirk cousins the
chicago bears
one of the reasons that i've decided
they should be interested in carson
wentz is
there really a lot of other options out
there a year with ben roethlisberger to
just
try to see what they can do you think
the bears should be or would be
interested in that
i think the bears could be interested in
that i don't know if
they should be i don't know how much
better he really makes them than
mitchell trubisky because
at least trubisky can kind of do some
things with his legs and maybe make some
plays a little bit
but they've they've got to make sure
that they can continue to have allen
robinson too
who's going to be a free agent i don't
know if they want to franchise him or
not especially with the way the cap is
going to be
but look i think that he that's another
team that
could make sense for ben roethlisberger
if i'm him
i might be interested in chicago if i'm
chicago
i don't know how interested i would be
in ben roethlisberger
see that's the thing i keep coming back
to i just the
the name is not going to create the kind
of instant sizzle that it would have a
few years ago that philip rivers did
last year that tom brady did last year
that the prospect is kind of vague
prospect that maybe drew brees would go
play for someone else he's made it clear
time and again he wouldn't
you know three years ago i remember
saying hey vikings instead of going
after a guy like kirk cousins just go
get drew brees he's out there he's a
free agent make him an offer whatever
you'd pay cousins offered a breeze
but brees has never been a guy who had
never been a guy and clearly at this
point he's retiring
but uh the sizzle that was there with
other guys
it's just not there for me with ben nfc
south we talked about the saints briefly
buccaneers have tom brady atlanta
falcons have a ton of money invested in
matt ryan and julio jones it looks like
they're not moving on from them and
they're going to be in a capped
nightmare as well the panthers have been
trying to find an upgrade at quarterback
and who knows what they may be plotting
are they plotting a run at desean watson
are they thinking about making a run at
russell wilson could they maybe try to
get the first overall pick in the draft
if all those things fail are they a team
are they a team that that maybe would
say
hey we want a great quarterback we'll
take a year with ben if we can get it
um i think interesting i mean i i think
that
i think that matt rule could maybe
go for ben roethlisberger i think it
would be an upgrade over teddy
bridgewater
the issue i think would be then what's
next i mean you have to be able
to get somebody behind him and say all
right this is our plan
for the future because i mean i know
matt rule's got a really long contract
that's also very lucrative but
at the same time you have to have a
really clear plan i think
for what the qb position is going to be
in the future
although the other thing there is that
uh david tepper
used to be a steelers minority owner so
maybe there's that connection that would
bring those two together
and i don't know maybe that could you
know result in a marriage for a year or
another
two years perhaps but i i i don't know
how much of an upgrade he would be over
teddy bridgewater but i think he would
be at least
somewhat of an upgrade over him it's
also possible that tepper spent enough
time behind the curtain to say no thank
you
we're good we're we're good we'll we'll
go with will greer
uh thank you very much nfc west where
two of the teams the
two teams that ben beat for super bowl
championships reside the seahawks and
the cardinals obviously the cardinals
have
caller murray the seahawks have russell
wilson i can't imagine them
moving russell wilson to have a one-year
stint with ben roethlisberger
the rams are stafford the only team
there
worth even discussing would be the 49ers
but
to the extent that kyle shanahan wants
basically a robotic quarterback who runs
the offense exactly the way he wants
does exactly what he
thinks and and and just submits fully to
the coaches authority
i don't think ben's gonna be doing that
although
if look if you are ben and you're
looking at the teams in the nfc
one that would stand out would be the
49ers when you consider the talent that
they have so i could see him being
interested in them
i have a hard time thinking they'd be
interested in him miles yeah
exactly i don't think that they would be
very interested in him
i don't know how much of an upgrade he
would be over jimmy garoppolo other than
the fact that ben roethlisberger starts
a bunch of games
and jimmy garoppolo's big problem is
that he just can't really stay healthy
and you know he goes out there and i
think he knows how to run the offense
pretty well
um in garoppolo but yeah i wouldn't
understand why the 49ers would have any
interest
in ben roethlisberger last year tom
brady wanted to play for the 49ers and
the 49ers evaluated and said no thank
you now there may be a certain amount of
regret they're feeling
given that tom brady won the super bowl
with the buccaneers but i don't think
that regret manifests itself in
hey we have an opportunity to get a guy
who's even younger than brady was
let's let's take him instead i still
don't think they're going to keep
garoppolo but
i don't think ben roethlisberger is the
alternative
that they find the the other issue is if
he's available what kind of money is he
going to be looking for especially in a
year
where the cap is depressed last year
when it was rivers breeze
and brady all free agents they all got
25 million for last year
and i think if ben is available and
somebody is interested in him
i don't think he's going to be at 25
million i think it's going to be more
like
15 million he's due to make 19 this year
and he said i don't care about what i
make this year but but i i just
it's easy to say it i i don't care about
my pay at all this year
that's easy to say it's harder to sign
the contract
that's the thing and i really do believe
at some level there's a disconnect
between what he wants and what he says
look he's only going to go through this
one time in his life there's no playbook
there's no magic sheet of answers that
you rattle
off and you're processing all of your
emotions
at a time when you're making these
comments and saying these things
and if he leaves the steelers he doesn't
want the perception to be
that he wanted too much money he doesn't
want to be the bad guy
you could still make a decent amount of
money over the court not not that he
needs it but we've seen steelers players
kind of hang around and be
beloved and have opportunities and and
you know you get money for nothing you
go golfing for free you're you're you
know you're just you're
still part of the club if you're
perceived as being greedy on your way
out the door maybe you won't be so
i just i i i'd like to attach ben
roethlisberger
to a lie detector test and uh
i want do you do you really want to play
and do you really want to play for the
steelers or are you just looking
for a graceful way out and
uh at some level i feel like that may be
the truth here
yeah anytime somebody says i don't
really care what i make i don't believe
them i i just
frankly i just don't i never do because
everybody cares what they make
they do and i don't if you could be jeff
bezos
or you could be anybody you know making
minimum wage
you care about how much money you make
and so from that perspective i get
that ben roethlisberger is probably
trying to be graceful
as he goes out because yes he has made a
lot of money
as the quarterback of the pittsburgh
steelers but saying i don't know
you know i don't care what i make this
year yes you do i'm sorry you do
everybody does and that's fine i think
that that's a human thing it's a normal
thing to care about how much money you
make
but if that's going to be the case where
you know you need to restructure
then there's got to be i guess some sort
of bar
to say this is what i'm willing to pay
for because
at that play for i should say because at
that point
there's got to be some sort of line
drawn
anywhere because you can't just say i
don't really care yes you do
everybody cares and there's already a
baseline of what you're going to make
already
so from that perspective yeah he could
be trying to find
a graceful way out but saying i don't
care what i make it just
it doesn't ring true to me i like that
lie detector test too mike
here's the other side of it miles and we
talked about this last year as it
related to philip rivers getting 25
million from the colts because
when you look brees brady rivers all
getting 25 who doesn't belong and why
it's rivers but but
the locker room pays attention how much
respect
is the rest of the team going to have
for the guy who walks through the door
making peanuts now it worked for the
patriots with cam newton
he walked through the door making
peanuts but
the circumstances were very different
and he's he's still he's cam newton
there's something about cam newton that
even if he is making minimum wage when
he walks into the locker room
the jaws are going to drop for the
players who are in there
i i don't know that you know if ben
shows up making the the
league minimum he's going to have that
same impact and i agree with you
just because he says i don't care what i
make that doesn't mean anything
if anything he does care what he makes
he's just trying to make it look like
he's not being greedy
in pittsburgh because he doesn't want to
be viewed as
the bad guy he has been viewed as the
bad guy when he went through the stuff
in georgia in 2010
i remember listening to talk radio from
pittsburgh for a few days just to get an
idea of what they were saying and it was
as bad
as i've ever heard a team talk about its
starting quarterback or the fans of a
team
talk about its starting quarterback it's
amazing how he's got his redemption
i don't think he wants to blow that on
his way out the door and i think that's
why he said the things he said
and i think that's why he's acting like
he wants to play and also if he would
retire
technically he would owe the steelers 12
million dollars and
i don't know that they would or wouldn't
try to get some of that back
but maybe the answer is we just agree to
go our separate ways
and you don't owe us any money and we're
going to move forward with mason rudolph
and dwayne haskins or whoever else we
may happen to acquire
this off season all right hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports